Gotcha.
Um,
somebody told me Wolf Blitzer got on jeopardy and they exposed them.
Yes.
I remember reading that.
Well,
because you know,
people get on television,
they read off a teleprompter.
You think their brand,
they seem brilliant and then you get him alone.
About Louis goes on a jeopardy and wins.
What Lucy did he,
yeah.
Remember they have celebrities.
I once in a while.
When did you do that?
A couple of years ago.
Did he go on with regular people in when I forget who he's against.
I think it was other famous paper that makes sense.
Most famous Jonathan Groff.
Well,
he's a very smart,
well,
do you remember he went on jeopardy.
He against regular people.
Yeah.
He won the whole tournament.
A comic.
So folks don't take a slight does.
He's still right for there he is.
Wolf Blitzer minus $4,000 dumb ass.
Yeah.
It didn't work out so well.
Ah,
fuck it.
Fun.
It is hilarious.
You know,
people can pretend to be smart.
you read all right.
Shell prompter that give you the script,
you know.
But John was Jonathan Groff.
Does he still write for Conan?
It's a good question.
I don't know.
The last time I saw him,
uh,
but he was fucking really,
really bright.
Funny Guy Too and really funny.
Yeah.
I don't think he does stand up anymore though.
Lead just rights.
That's how smart he is.
And he's like,
enough of this nonsense is jokey joke.
Non said enough is enough.
I'm starting to feel that way.
Um,
but why,
why do you hate CNN?
I'll come on all the fucking shit they put out there.
And uh,
just an example,
how about before the went Donna Brazil had the notes for Hillary before the
fucking Barney.
Yes.
Remember that.
Would this amount,
and not to discredit you,
CNN was,
she was a pond it right.
And they still had a run.
That's what's coming to us that they had her on after that.
He told Dale questions we're going to be,
yeah.
Well her book was amazing though,
that that's what's interesting is they fucked her over and then she came into a
book and then rip them.
I have it.
I haven't read it yet.
Similar classes,
just so they put the,
what I read about how they rigged the DNC is how they,
how they,
uh,
Fuck Bernie out of the primaries.
Yeah.
Woo Woo.
Bernie gets screwed.
It's a dark business.
Fucking,
it's all the same.
They're all in coach.
But you don't think like the mainstream media is a little like a propaganda arm
for the Democratic Party?
Well,
they definitely negative coverage.
They definitely think they're working for the good,
but it's the 3% negative coverage with Trump.
Trump is,
and you know,
he's an unusually polarizing figure.
Sure.
I mean,
was it that way with,
um,
I guess I was probably pretty negative with Bush all.
It was a different world back then.
No it was,
but they always,
since I've been a kid,
I mean Reagan was a dummy and just to fucking be actor and an idiot,
no racist.
You can look at the ship year after year was true of George Bush,
senior George W.
Bush,
Dick Cheney warmonger.
But it's the same shit,
racist,
bigot race and it works and forth.
Board was a moron and Ford was,
remember how he's portrayed on SNL?
He was always falling.
He couldn't walk three feet,
which was kind of trow actually has got it.
And he was an athlete,
but it,
but it's always been that way.
The mainstream media has always sort of been more liberal.
But then you have Fox News,
which goes far the other way.
Well,
what their opinion shows.
But at least when you watch Fox knows,
which everybody who hates Fox,
who's never watches it,
number one.
Uh,
but,
but they at least have liberals on and Shepard Smith.
Yes and hates.
Yes he does.
He looks like every guy that bullied him as a kid.
Do you think that's why I hate them?
Yeah,
that's it.
That's the only reason.
The only way to raise,
and most of them hate him.
He,
here's what,
here's what they don't bring up.
Even Hannity and all these guys,
you get your head going like a,
of fuck.
What's change?
A second that he's getting irritated with me already.
I gotta get you out of La.
I'm afraid you're going to get disease and everything's good.
Over nine.
Tell me about it.
Uh,
but uh,
what,
what were you just talking about?
Why they hate Trump?
Because they never bring up this though.
They never cause he's a alpha male,
blonde haired,
blue eyed fucking billionaire.
That is the,
that's the embodiment of the devil for the left.
They never bring that up on the shelf.
Do you think that's really what it is?
Has nothing to do with him lying all the time and lie about the number of people
at his inauguration as opposed to Obama going,
oh,
you can keep your healthcare.
I mean the fucking,
you know,
he doesn't lie any more than any other president.
You don't think so?
If he does,
it's trivial shit.
He's a salesman.
He's a,
there's a fine line,
but it's definitely a salesman.
But Oh,
he's a bullshitter.
But that's what we need.
We're a cooperation where corporate the countries don't think so.
That's what I always heard.
It's kind of like that little bit.
I mean,
it's some,
some sort of an organization.
He really is.
Hillary Clinton Lion.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Well,
why don't you get called on it?
How's that fat Twat?
Not In cups.
Oh,
how dare you.
It is.
Good question.
You know?
Yeah,
it's a great question.
I was talking to Mike Baker who used to work for the CIA.
Oh,
I thought you meant my fucking web guy cause he bugging.
He wanted to come out here with me and Mike Baker from the CIO is if he,
if he did anything remotely like what Hillary did,
he'd be in jail for 30 years.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
I remember the kid in the submarine that worked for the Navy,
he took pictures of submarine.
I mean he liked took a selfie and it had bad shit in the background that it
wasn't supposed to take photos of.
And how long was he in jail?
I don't know.
I would just like to see some equity as far as people being held accountable on
both sides.
That's how maybe it would have been different if Hillary made it through.
Maybe it would have been different in terms of like media coverage.
If she actually became president,
they would have sucked her ass.
Yeah,
I think so.
I don't know.
Man Wants Donna Brazile's book came out and people have an understanding about
the inner workings of the Party.
I mean,
I think look it politics or it's dirty,
dirty business.